very good morning everyone I welcome you all on behalf of TC Sajjan for the fourth session
of IIT Karaktu AI4I CPS Certificate Program. Today we have two sessions, first one is
"Ladier Model for Regression and Classification" which will be given by Sudejna Sarka Mam IIT KGB
and the second one is "Supervised for Mission Learning Part 1" which will be given by Abhijan
Chakraborty Sir IIT KGB. Participants before going to the session we have
other instructions for you all to set up the Webex layout please click on the stack mode
and enable full screen mode which will be in the top right corner of the screen. Webex
session will be unique and shared every week over email community and via course batch.
A raw recording of the today's session will be available by end of the day and edited
recording will be available on Monday. Week 4 assignment will be enabled at 2pm today
and the submission for week 3 assignment deadline is on 2nd of March which is on tomorrow
Sunday till 11pm and the solution for the assignment will be available on 3rd of March
Monday at 11am. Assignments are being evaluated by IIT KGB team and you will be notified shortly.
And today we have a quiz for week 3 and the timings will be 5pm to 7pm so please ensure
you are available to attend the quiz during the quiz window and the results for the assignment
will be available at 9pm today. To view your marks obtained you can click on the attempts
taken column in the quiz note. So WhatsApp notification address will be sent only for
those who have given consent in the platform. Participants if you have any issues, concerns
you can reach out to us at the disk email id info.tssion@tsis.com. Thank you everyone
for joining in today's session. Thank you ma'am over to you.
Very good morning to everybody. So today we will be talking about some very basic machine
learning methods, basic introduction to machine learning and linear models for classification
and regression. If you have any questions please send those questions. Okay so before
I start with linear models I will give you a brief overview of what is machine learning.
So if you look at you know the total spectrum of AI, the main three pillars of AI is modeling
or representation, learning and inferencing. So we from through learning we get models
and these models are used to make inferences. So these three are well connected. So today
we hear about learning a lot and machine learning has embedded every sphere and have you know
impacted all our lives and put many more tunes at our fingertips. So let us get to the basics
of what learning is all about. Learning in general is the ability to learn from data,
to evolve behaviors, to behave in a more optimum way based on data or experience. So given
past data or past experiences we build a model and this model can be used for inferencing
tasks such as prediction, decision making or solving problems. So in this context there
are certain terminology, task is what you want to solve is the problem that you have
in hand, data is the experience that you have on the basis of which you are trying to learn
a model to solve the task better. And when you develop a model you want to also be able
to evaluate and learn and know how the model is performing so we have measures of improvement.
So if we think of you know developing a learner, simple learners which we will talk about in
this particular class. So we will have a problem a task and instance of the task we will have
some input. Let us say x is the input and machine learn through machine learning we
will learn a model let us say f is the model. So that for the input x we want to predict
y. Now some of you have written computer programs, in computer programs you write functions which
take some input, give some output. So you take an array of numbers and you have an algorithm
which produce the sorted numbers or you take an array and you tell whether the array is
sorted or not. So the input is x, the output is y. Now f is the function which will get
you from the input to the output and this f is what we want to learn, f is the model
which we want to learn. Now there are three aspects to the machine learning model. The
first aspect is representation. So for a particular task, how should x be represented? What is
the input that the machine learning model should take? That is the issue of representation
and today we have made great strides in being able to represent different types of tasks
but that you will learn later. Today we will talk only about simple representations.
The second aspect is once we have the representation, we have x and we have data and the data that
we will consider today is of the form of x y pairs. So now we want to come up with f,
the best f which for x will try to mostly give the correct y and in order to find this
f, we run an optimization algorithm to find a good f and once we have found the f, we
have some evaluation metrics to test how f is true.
Now what do we say about representation? Representation is how we are representing
the model. So we have some data, we take some features of the data and the model is in terms
of the features of the data. For example, suppose you want to predict the price of a
house, ok. Now so for a house if you want to predict the price, we might want to abstract
the features of the house. For example, how big is the house? What is the square foot
area? How many rooms are there? What is the construction material? So we want to identify
features so that in terms of the features we can design our function f. So for this particular
class, we will look at a representation which is a vector. So it can be a single feature
or multiple features that is a vector of features. So our x in general is a vector of n features
x 1, x 2, x n. We will call them x 1, x 2, x n, ok. Now today we will talk about structured
features only, but nowadays in machine learning we work with all types of data. For example,
text data, image data, video data, these are called unstructured data and for unstructured
data we can take the text, video, etcetera as input and then you know most of the machine
learning neural network models that we use, they will learn a representation to convert
this into a vector of features, may be one dimensional 2D, 3D, etcetera depending on
how your representation is. Now once we have the features, we learn a model. So model is
a function of the features. Now what type of function? So you can have simple functions
like linear functions, you can other functions like let us say quadratic function or a cascade
of different functions or a decision tree. So there are various models possible. Today
we will talk about the simplest of the models. These are some models for example a linear
function, the function is a linear function of x 1, x 2, x n. So y is x 1 is a function
of w 1, x 1, w 2 plus w 2, x 2 plus w 3, w n, x n plus w 0. So this is a linear function.
Today we will talk only about linear functions. Later you will see that there are other possible
functions like decision tree, like different graphical models like neural networks which
you must have heard a lot about. Now the richard the model, you know the linear
function is the simplest model. If you have little data and your task is simple then you
can use linear functions and you can learn it quickly. But if you have more complex you
know underlying behavior, then you will not be able to do with work with linear functions.
Then you will go for more complex functions which have higher representational power.
Now in order to learn this function we take some data and for this particular tasks which
we will talk about today regression and classification tasks, the data is of this form. It is different
x y tuples. So we look at past data. So house 1 and its price, we want to find the price
of a house. House 1, so the x 1 is the features of house 1 and y 1 is the price of house 1.
House 2 is the features of house 2 and y 2 is the price of house 2. So we can have let
us say data about 200 houses. So we have x 1, y 1, x 2, y 2, x m, y m let us say m equal
to 200. This is the data that we have and from this data we are going to learn a model.
So that this model for you know the houses that we have will predict the price accurately.
So the training, so in machine learning we have the training to learn the model. During
training we take the training data and learn a model from the training data. So that given
a new house which we have not come across before we can accurately predict the price
of the house. So our model, so the model that we have y is the function of x and we have
to learn f and the function f we parameterize in terms of theta ok.
So we talked about w 1 x 1 plus w 2 x 2 we can also say w 1 w 2 these are the model parameters
theta ok. So what is theta theta are the parameters. So if we assume that the form of f is let us
say w 0 or let me just write theta 0 plus theta 1 x 1 plus theta n x n.
So what is theta? Theta is the collection of the parameters, so these are the parameters.
So f is a function of theta ok. So what is our objective in machine learning? The optimization
objective is that given a particular form of this model suppose you decide that you
are going to use a linear model which has this particular form you want to find the
best values of theta. So that for those values of theta the prediction y equal to f theta
x is most accurate. What do you mean by most accurate? We have to come up with a performance
measure and in terms of that performance measure we have to find the best theta ok.
So training involves learning the model from the training data, erase this part. And so
that given a new instance x prime you can accurately predict the corresponding y prime.
So in machine learning the training phase what we are showing here is where you have
a training data, training set which is your input and from this so training set may be
in a 200 houses. And then you decide what are the features that you are going to consider
about the house. Let us say area of the house, number of bedrooms, the edge of the house.
Let us say you decide these 3 features. So your feature extractor will take the house
and for each house it will find these 3 features. It will find x in a for house 1 it will find
x 1 1, x 1 2, x 1 3. For house 2 x 2 1, x 2 2, x 2 3. So these are the input features
of every house and then you know what is the target price. Now you want to your machine
learning algorithm will come up with a model F theta which given a particular house comes
price to predict its price. So this is the training phase at the end of the training
phase you will have a model and this model is F theta. Now when we want to use the model
then that is the testing phase or the phase where you use it. So in the testing phase
you will use this model which was learnt in the training phase and given a new house new
input it you will extract the features of that input or the features of the house in
this case use F theta and predict the price of the house ok.
So if you have any questions please let us know. Now we will look at 2 types of learning
problems. The first one type of learning problem the first one that we will look at is called
regression where y is a numerical value such as the price of the house. Given a house we
want to predict its price and the price is a numerical value. The second type of learning
problem that we will look at is the classification problem where the output is a class. For example
given a picture you want to find out is it a picture of a cat or not or is it a picture
of a cat dog horse or none of these. So the output is a classification ok. So that is
a or you can say given you know the features of a house you want to classify it as high
end or mid end right that is a classification problem the output is a class ok.
So we will look at regression problems first followed by classification problems and in
this particular class we will talk about linear models for the regression problem given the
features suppose we have 2 features X 1 and X 2 ok. So we will learn a linear function
in terms of X 1 and X 2 where you know given for a particular house the value of X 1 and
X 2 we can find what is the value price of the house. The other task that we will look
at as classification problem where given the input X 1 and X 2 we will learn a linear function.
So that on one side of the linear function we have high end house and the other side
of the linear function we have low end house. So in classification we will use the linear
function as a decision boundary. So that at one side is class 1 the other side is class
2 for regression we will use a linear function which will directly give me the value of Y.
Now let us look at some example tasks of regression and classification. So one example that we
have been talking about is predicting the price of a house. Another example is given
a machinery in a plant we want to estimate the remaining useful life of the machine.
So that we know that when the machine should be replaced or maintained. A third example
of our regression problem is for a particular component in a plant we want to find what
is the probability that it will develop a crack. Given the features of that object we
want to say find out estimate whether it is likely to develop a crack or not and output
what is the probability that it will develop cracks.
Fourth example is forecasting demand of a you know some items in some say. Some examples
of classification task object identification of images like cat or dog you know you have
images of digits you want to say with 0 or 1 or 2 or 9. Defect classification defective
object or non-defective object identify whether a credit card transaction is a fraud or not
these are examples of classification tasks. Now let us come back to our favorite problem
of house price prediction. Let us say that we come up with these features the area of
the house, the material quality, the number of bedrooms, the area of the garage. So these
are some features that we have come up with. Now we want to we are assuming that there is
a linear function in terms of these features which is a good fit to give us an estimate
of the house price and we have to come up with the model and today now we will talk
about linear models but you can use any other model.
So as we said we have the training set. So if we have examples data about 200 houses then
we use our learning algorithm and we are going to talk about the learning algorithm for linear
models today in this class and then we come up with f theta the model this is our model.
So that given a new house its value of x we can predict its y. Now this f that we have
been talking about we sometimes call it h or you know just h and whatever terminology
we use this is our hypothesis function. This is our hypothesis function and if this function
for example the linear function in terms of some parameters theta 0 plus theta 1 x 1 plus
theta 2 x 2. So these are called the model parameters. So theta are called the model
parameters. So we can write h or we can write h theta where we explicitly say theta are
the parameters of the model. Now if you look at a classification task this
is an example of a classification task. There are three species of the iris flower right
and if you take a number of iris flowers and you identify that the features are length
of the sepul, width of the sepul, length of the petal, width of the petal and it is found
that by using these four features you can have a fairly accurate in a model which classifies
the given flower in one of these three classes quite accurately. So here we are just showing
two features sepul length and sepul width and there are three types of iris setosa,
versicolor and virginica and they are shown in colors red, green and blue. We see that
in terms of sepul width and sepul length we cannot completely classify these three classes
using linear models but we can classify setosa versus the other species using a linear model
fairly accurately. So suppose you use this linear separator this decision surface you
know you can find the equations of this line so that the setosa mostly lie on one side
of this line and the other iris species lie on the other side of the line.
So for supervised learning the training data we will have you know these are our features
we have four features as we said x 1, x 2, x 3, x 4 and this is the value of y and we
have three classes we denote them by s vs and vg. So in the y column the value will be
one of these classes. So this is my training set during testing we will test the model
with some new flowers and for those flowers we give the value of the features and your
machine learning the model that you learn your algorithm will be applied on the training
data and the algorithm will give a model f theta. Now you apply f theta on the test set
and you will predict these values. Now there are two ways in which you can apply classification
problem one is you predict the actual class. The other way of looking at the classification
problem is the first way is there are three types of iris flower you predict whether it
is type 1, type 2 or type 3. The other way of doing classification is you have let us
say three classes for every object you predict what is the probability it belongs to type
1, the probability that it belongs to type 2 and the probability of belonging to type
3. So instead of telling that this object is this class you can output the probabilities
of each class. So this is a another way of looking at the classification problem and
you can easily move from this to this. For example, if you have to give the class you
can give the max of this probabilities to find out what is the more likely category.
But these probabilistic values give you more flexibility. For example, suppose you know
that this is either virginica or what is the other name I forgot it is either virginica
or versicolor. So maybe you say type 1 is setosa is 0.1 this is 0.4 this is 0.5 you
know so this can quantify your confidence in the class.
Now with this background let us come to linear models. So as I said in linear model we assume
that our model is in terms of a linear function. First let us take a very simple example where
we have a single feature right. So our linear model is y equal to theta 0 plus theta 1 x
x is the only feature. So there are two parameters theta 0 and theta 1 ok and they are referred
to as theta. So theta is the vector of parameters theta 0 theta 1. So we are assuming that y
is a linear function of x and what is what does our algorithm A do? A learns the best
values of theta 0 theta 1 and what do you mean by best values of theta 0 theta 1? Based
on the training set you arrive at this best value so that with those values the model
is able to you know correctly identify the target in the training set. Now this is if
you have a single feature but what if you have multiple features? Suppose you have these
two features living area and bedroom then your function will be y equal to theta 0 plus
theta 1 x 1 plus theta 2 x 2 ok. So it in terms of this linear function in terms of these
two features ok. So this picture this is a surface which is a linear surface in terms
of two features. Now so this is my model this is my linear
model that we have talked about when there are n features in general and sometimes we
canwrite it in a compact notation theta vector dot x vector. What is the theta vector? Theta
vector is theta 0 theta 1 theta n and what is x vector? x vector is x 1 x 2 x n ok. So
we have the theta 0 which is the bias in the linear function and sometimes we will incorporate
x 0 and set it to 1 ok and then we can write this as a dot product of the theta vector
and the x vector. This is a compact notation of this linear function and in vector notation
you can also write that theta transpose x ok these are just notations for this linear
function vector. So in this picture we have you know different
you know single x and the corresponding y ok. In the upper picture we have a single
feature x and the corresponding y and this blue dots represent the different items in
the training set. For example, if you look at this item its x value is 28 and y value
is 6. For this item let us say x value is 44 and the y is 12 ok. Now like this we have
numerous you know let us say 100 different objects. Now we want to fit a straight line
so that for every x we can get the correct y. Now if you look at this picture you see
that there is no line for so that there is no linear function so that for every x you
can give the exact value of y. But you can find a good line this red line that we have
drawn is a line so that you know the error of for a particular x when you predict the
value of y, the error with respect to the actual is very small ok. Similarly, if you
look at the bottom picture we have two features x 1 and x 2 and we are predicting the value
of y and suppose this grey you know plane that is our you know our linear hypothesis.
This is our linear hypothesis in two dimensions. Now the actual points are given by these black
dots and we can find out how much there is an error of this given decision surface with
respect to the actual points. So, that is the error. So, the error in the top case you
know for every point we can find out how far it is from the red line that is the error
of this model. Now there can be multiple lines possible multiple red lines possible. So,
for each red line you have some error. Now you want to find out that line for which that
error is smallest that is your learning problem. If there any major questions let me know let
me know the major questions. So, that I can handle the questions now ok.
So, when talking about linear functions we want to find this values of theta 0, theta
1, theta n and so which basically says what is the best line given the training set which
means learn the values of theta i. Multi-variate regression means regression when there is
more than one variable. Now what you call is up to you, but it mainly means that you
have multiple variables. Anything else? Why use theta transpose here? Because theta is
a row vector x is a row vector if we transpose theta we get a column vector and column vector
and x vector that is the multiplication which is defined theta dot x is basically theta
transpose x ok. Classification can be binary if it is a two classes, but if there are three
classes like the iris case there will be three classes. There can be any number of classes
10 classes 20 classes. How do we decide the parameter set that is what we are going to
talk about now ok. Now, so they did ask the questions come you can just write and come
here interact me ok. So, now as I said that you know this is the suppose this red line
is my model suppose this is my model F1 ok. Now for the model F1 if these dots these blue
dots are our actual training data and this red line is a model F1 then what is the error
of this model? So, if you look at this for this value of x it is predicting this value
of y and the red line is saying the value of y should be this for this particular value
of x. So, the error is this much for this blue point the error is very small for this
blue point for given x the y being predicted is this the actual value is this. So, this
is the error. So, for every point we can find the error ok distance from the line you know
some quantification we will do. So, these are the errors for the points it is these lines
the each line is a error of an individual point if you sum them up we get the total error
or we can average them to get the average error.
Now suppose we have another line ok we have another line and for that line you know the
error will be different this is the error for this point this is the error for this point
this is the error ok. So, we can have errors for this line. So, this line is my F2. So,
we will have error for F1 error for F2. Now out of these two models possible models F1
and F2 which one should I prefer? I can add up the errors for F1 I can find what is the
error of F1 I can find the error of F2 and of course which one should I choose? I will
choose out of F1 and F2 that model for which the F1 is smaller, but there are so many possible
models there are so many possible lines how many lines are possible? An infinite number
of lines are possible right. So, we cannot enumerate all possible lines and find the
error of all the lines and then choose the best line.
So, we are going to use a clever optimization method one clever optimization method. So,
that given these training points we can find that F we want to find that F let me call
this F star. So, that error of F star is less than equal to error of any F which is a linear
function. So, once we decide we want to consider only the class of linear functions I want
to find that linear function whose error is the minimum among all possible linear functions
you know the all possible linear functions I want to find that for which that linear function
for which the error is smallest and of course we want to do it without enumerating all the
lines. So, this is my learning problem. So, coming back here. So, we have you know this
is my potential F and then the error is the we can take as the sum of the individual losses.
So, we can say error equal to sum of y hat i minus y i what is y i. So, x i is my ith
training example and y i is the actual output of x i actual you know for suppose x i is
the area of the ith house y i is the actual price of the house. And what is y i hat it
is the predicted y i hat is if you are considering a particular F with a particular parameter
theta. So, y i is F theta of x i. So, ideally you want y i to be close to y i hat ideally
you want y i hat should be equal to y i, but that is not always possible you know given
these points it is not possible to get a line which will fit the price perfectly and you
know that houses with the same area do not all have the same price. So, this model will
not capture exactly the price of each house, but we can find the error y i hat minus y
i. And what is y i hat y i hat is just F theta x i or h theta x i. So, error of the ith training
instance is y i hat minus y i or F theta x i minus y i this is the prediction error for
the ith instance. If we consider m instances the total training set we can sum them up.
Now in order to find this error we can take the Euclidean distance between this instance.
So, or we can take rather in not Euclidean we can take the squared error because the
actual error here the error is negative for this error is positive. So, if you have some
places where the error is positive and some cases where the error is negative if you add
them up you may get a small value right. So, if you want to add them up we can add up the
absolute values of the error or what is usually done is that we add up the squared error.
So, this is the sum square error and then we take an average because there
are m points we divide by m to get the mean square error. And we want to minimize the
mean square error. We want to learn theta because every theta for one particular value
of theta you have this line another value of theta you have this line for another value
of theta you have this line. So, you want to find that line for which the mean square
error is smallest that is you want to find the values of theta for which the mean square
error is smallest. So, that is why we define the lost function as the average of the squared
error. And you may be wondering what this 2 is doing it does not matter if you want
to minimize the mean square error you can also minimize half of the mean square error
we are just keeping the half as a factor for convenience is this clear any question so
far. So, what would be the impact in slide 17 if the order of the you know feature changes
of you tell me what will be the impact you have theta 0 plus theta 1 x 1 plus theta 2
x 2 right. Now, instead of x 1 suppose x 1 becomes z 2 x 2 becomes z 1. So, you will
have theta 0 plus theta 1 theta 2 z 2 plus theta 1 z 1 you see if the order of the feature
changes or the in there is no impact when you learn theta, thetas will be different
the best values of theta will be different because you are adding you know you are when
you are adding something the order you know where it occurs in the addition expression
does not make it matter any other question. In a changing data set where the parameter
value changes you know for it firstly when you change a data set parameter values are
what you are learning when new data come in now the optimum values of the parameters will
change right. If you have some data you learn the parameters so that with respect to that
data you have the optimum values of the parameters, but if the data set changes the optimum values
of the parameter will change, one of the solutions is to redo the model or incrementally modify
the model ok. So, there are two options one is if you have time you can run the model
again with the new data set or you can you know try to incorporate the effects of the
new data ok. So, both are possible anything else? Does feature in extraction involve
input data transformation it may it may involve transformation yes it is a separate step.
Today we are talking about once we have got the feature set in terms of that what is the
linear function how you get the feature set we are not talking about explicitly today
right. You know for example for the house price you talk about the domain expert to
identify the features and then you know suppose you are taking an image or a video we have
today machine learning model which automatically come up with features right using neural network
you know there are transformations to get the features that we will learn later yeah.
Cost function loss function they are used synonymously mean the same thing yeah anything
ok. Thank you let us proceed now that we have defined the cost function ok. So, this is
my loss function and let us try to visualize it. So, my loss function if you look at is
a quadratic function and if you plot a quadratic function now what is it a function of suppose
there is only one feature and the there will be two parameters theta 0 and theta 1. So,
if you visualize a quadratic function in terms of theta 0 and theta 1 it will be a convex
function ok. An example of a convex function is given here. So, any quadratic function
is a convex function and if you just look at this you know what is it that you are trying
to do for you know some value of theta 0 theta 1. So, this is a plot of this loss function.
So, for different values of theta 0 and theta 1 you get different values of loss what is
your objective? Your objective is to get that value of theta 0 theta 1 for which the loss
is smallest because we have this square function the loss is always positive right and in this
convex surface we want to find that point in this loss surface where the loss is smallest.
Now, since this quadratic function is a convex function there is a unique value of theta
0 theta 1 which has the smallest loss and the objective of our learning algorithm is
to find that value of theta 0 and theta 1 where loss is minimized. So, our learning
algorithm means find the value of the parameter. So, as to minimize loss now for linear models
where the loss surface is convex there is a unique value of theta 0 theta 1 for which
loss is smallest and there are good algorithms which will help us find the exact value of
theta 0 theta 1 and we will talk about these algorithms now.
So, now we talk about minimizing the cost function or minimizing the loss function they
mean the same thing. Now, so this is my loss function ok this is my loss function. Now,
I want to find theta 0 and theta 1 so that the loss is smallest. Now, there are two ways
of doing it which I will talk about today. The first way is by using basic calculus.
So, some of you must be familiar with calculus I hope most of you are familiar with calculus.
In calculus we know that when you have a maxima or minima the derivative at the minima is
0. If you have a function right when the function which is with minima the derivative or the
tangent to this curve is 0 at other places the tangent is non 0. So, the tangent at the
minima is 0 similarly the tangent at the maxima is also 0. Now, for this particular quadratic
function we saw that there is a unique minima and at that minima there is no maxima minima
at the minima the derivative is 0. So, what we will do is that we will find out where
in this equation the derivative is 0. Now, the derivative will be 0 with respect to both
the parameters theta 0 and theta 1. So, we can set d L d theta 0 equal to 0 and d L d
theta 1 equal to 0. And if we set this for example by setting d L d theta 1 equal to
0. Now, L is given by this equation we can differentiate this and we will get this expression.
You can go through this in detail I will just cover it at a high level. So, you see this
is a you know in order to do this derivative there are tricks that we have learnt in high
school suppose you can set z equal to theta 0 plus theta 1 x i minus y i whole square.
So, you set this equal to z you know basically this equal to z let me clean this up. So,
this is my z now and the z is this. So, I can say d L d theta 1 equal to d L d z times
d z d theta 1. So, what is d L d z L equal to summation of z square. So, you know again
so we can using that we can write. So, if you have z square the derivative is 2 z and
if you take d L d z d L d z it is 2 z and then d z d x 0 right with sorry d z d theta
0 then it will be equal to 1. So, in terms of this if you simplify this is what you get
and then if you set it to 0 you get this formula. Similarly, from d L d theta 1 equal to 0
you will get another formula and if you solve these two equations we get the close form
values of theta 0 and theta 1. I am not going it to detail it is not typical, but you please
work it out and we get theta 0 is equal to 1 by m summation i equal to 1 to m by i minus
theta 1 summation i equal to 1 to m x i ok and similarly we get some value of theta 1.
So, this is the closed form solution to linear regression ok. So, this is a closed form solution
to linear regression and any questions ok. Now, this is for a single variable if you
have multiple variables also you can derive a closed form solution I will not go into
the details of the derivation because that will require working with matrix algebra and
some of you may not be familiar with matrix algebra, but there exists a closed form solution
and this is the solution. You can find the theta vector in terms of x is the matrix of
you know there are m rows corresponding to the m instances and there are n columns plus
1 column for the bias for the n features. So, that is the matrix x. So, it turns out
that theta can be obtained by x transpose x then whole thing inverse x transpose multiplied
by the y vector. So, there exists a closed form solution we are not going into the derivation
of this solution, but this solution exists. So, using this equation if you are given a
training set you know m instances each having a x vector and the corresponding y you can
use this matrix transformation transpose product inverse to get a closed form solution which
gives you the optimum values of theta 0 theta 1 theta m. So, you get the best linear model,
so that with respect to the training data it gives you the minimum loss.
Now, so why for this particular task a closed form solution exists I am going to talk about
another method which is an iterative solution and the reason I am going to talk about this
iterative solution is that it is more general and it can be used in many other types of
functions right. For simple linear regression you do have an analytic solution, but there
are other forms of models for which you do not have analytical solution and for many
of these models you can use this wonderful optimization method called gradient descent.
So, in machine learning gradient descent is going to be your friend because you are going
to use it you can use it in many cases. So, let me explain the gradient descent solution
to linear regression. Now, so what we told is that if you have a linear function your
error loss function is quadratic which is convex which has a single minima and if you
have a function which is a single minima then you know that you know at the minima the gradient
is 0, but if you start at any other point suppose you start at this point at this point this
is not an optimum point. So, its gradient will be non-zero. So, this gradient is positive.
So, if the gradient is positive what does it mean? It means that you have to reduce
the values of the parameter why? Because you know the gradient is in the upward slope if
you go in the reverse direction of the gradient the parameter will give you those parameters
will give you a smaller value of loss. So, if you start at a particular place if you
move in the negative direction of the gradient with small steps it will get closer to the
minima it will get closer to the minima. Similarly if you start at this point your gradient
is negative. So, if you increase the value of the parameters then your error is going
to reduce if you increase it by a little bit you know. So, you have to move in the negative
direction of the gradient. So, if you have multiple parameters theta 0 theta 1 theta
n. So, at the minima the gradient with respect to each of theta 0 theta 1 theta n is 0. So,
you can have these gradients partial gradients with respect to the loss for the loss function
with respect to each of these parameters theta 0 theta 1 theta n. For each of the parameters
you find the gradient at the current. So, initially you start with some value of theta
you can randomly choose you start with the initial randomly chosen value of theta and
then you know suppose let me draw the curve again. So, this is my curve loss curve for
a particular value let us say theta 0. So, we have started with let us say this is my
guess for theta I have started with some arbitrary values of theta 0. Now, I find the gradient
I find that gradient is non 0. So, I modify theta 0 by reducing it because the gradient
is positive. So, I get a new value of theta let us call it theta 1 again I find that slope
is positive again I reduce it to get theta 2 I reduce it I reduce it until I come to
a point where my theta k is close to 0. And then I reduce this values of theta I reduce
it by small amounts why because if I reduce theta by a large amount I will overshoot and
come to this side, but if I go slowly I will reach a point where theta is close to 0. So,
this gives us the intuition about how we can use this understanding to have a nice simple
iterative algorithm. So, that we can start with some guess of the linear function and
try to modify the value of theta. So, we suppose we have two parameters theta 0 theta 1 we
will start with some initial values of theta 0 theta 1. Now, we will keep changing theta
0 theta 1 to reduce the loss function again you know these are two different notations
people very often use loss theta 0 theta 1 j theta 0 theta 1 error theta 0 theta 1 all
mean the same thing and we want to keep changing it. So, that we end up at the minimum.
Now this works well if the loss surface is convex, but if the loss surface is like the
picture that we have shown there are multiple minima where the loss is there. So, if you
start at a particular point if you use this particular formulation you will reach one
of the local minima we will talk about that later. But now when we are talking about linear
regression there is a single minima and what we have shown talked about is given in this
picture. So, if I start at the yellow point I find the derivative and I have to move in
the negative direction of the derivative which is reducing the value of theta. If I start
at the green point the derivative is negative. So, we have to increase the value of the theta
to reduce the error. And how we will change theta 0 theta 1 we will change it so that
we take a step in the negative direction of the gradient for each of theta 0 theta 1 here
I am showing the equation of theta 1, but for theta 0 also you have the same equation.
So, the new theta 1 is the old theta 1 minus alpha times this is the partial derivative
del del theta 1 of loss of theta 1 and what is alpha it is the step size. So, when I say
that if you start with the yellow point you take a step right alpha determines whether
the step size is big or small. If alpha is big the step size will be big if alpha is
small the step size will be small. So, this is how I start with any value of the parameters
and that every iterative step we modify the value of the parameters using the partial
derivative. This is a very important algorithm simple algorithm, but extremely influential
algorithm in machine learning. So, understand it properly ok.
So, if you have any questions please let me know during calculation why is there a 2 in
the denominator you know we just kept 2 because it does not matter firstly the solution will
be the same whether you keep the 2 or you do not keep 2 if we keep 2 the analytical solution
is nice. If you do not keep 2 the analytical solution will have a 2 in the numerator, there
is no other yeah it does not really matter it is just so that the analytical solution
has a good form ok. Any other question? If you assume that the loss topography is not
complex with many local minima's, but just one global minima. So, you know the gradient
descent algorithm will guarantee that you only go to a local minima it does not guarantee
a global minima, but when we have this complex surfaces for example, in neural networks you
know there are different other tricks etcetera. So, that you still get a good solution do
not get stuck with a bad local minima. There is no guarantee that when you use a neural
network you will get your global optimum a neural network is one where you have multiple
local minima. So, there is no guarantee, but there are tips and tricks so that you get
to a good minima ok. Any other question? Are MLE and EM we learnt in last session considered
specific type of loss functions EM is an algorithm optimization algorithm expectation
maximization. MLE is again an optimization algorithm right. So, MLE is you know you want
to get the average of a particular value and what is the best way to estimate it. EM is
an algorithm expectation maximization and we will come across the M algorithm when we
look at clustering and other things ok. So, M algorithm will may use some loss function
like squared error etcetera, but EM is a type of optimization framework ok and MLE is also
an optimization framework. Can we create custom loss functions? Yes, based on your requirement
you can create a loss function, but whatever the loss function you create this gradient
descent can be used with any loss function. If you can find the derivative, if the loss
function is differentiable then and or continuous if the loss function is continuous and piece
wise differentiable then you can use the gradient descent algorithm. Any other question? Thank
you.
So, I hope this gradient descent the basic idea is clear to everyone as I said this is
the very important algorithm in machine life ok. And yes for complex you know functions
that there are multiple global minima, there is no guarantee that you get to the minima,
but then you have to try to handle instead of making the optimization algorithm you know
complex. We use a simple optimization algorithm like gradient descent and use different tricks
ok. Now back to the slides, so the step size you keep small, but if you keep it too small
your number of iterations will become very large. If the step size is too small you take
a lot of time to converge, if the step size is large you will not converge, you may not
converge, you may overshoot at such a. So, the step size should be judiciously chosen.
Sometimes what people do is that initially they choose large step sizes, so that you
quickly move towards the minimum and as your derivative becomes you know in a quadratic
function the derivative will value of the derivative will reduce as you go towards the minima.
So, you know later you can make the derivative smaller ok, let me finish this now. Now how
to compute the partial derivative? So, we have already seen, but let us do it again.
So, this is my j theta again you know 1 by 2 m. So, 1 by m this is the sum of the squared
loss, 1 by m of this is the mean square loss. We have put 1 by 2, there is no reason to
put 1 by 2 because whatever the value of theta minimizes this equation also minimizes this
equation without the texture. You have just kept to so that when after we take the derivative
the function is smaller, no other. So, this is the general equation, theta j for each
parameter, if you have theta 0, theta 1, theta 2, theta n there will be n plus 1 parameter.
For each parameter theta j, the new theta j is all theta j minus alpha times del del
theta j of the loss function ok. And if this is my loss function, now we can compute. So,
so why we have taken this half? So, remember we can say that this is z, so z square when
you take derivative of z square you get 2 z, that 2 in the numerator cancels out this
2 in the denominator. So, if you do del del theta j theta bar you get 1 by m of this which
is which gives us this nice form ok. So, del del theta j of j theta bar is 1 by m summation
i equal to 1 to m yi hat minus yi times xji ok. So, this has a nice form. And therefore,
if this is my loss function here, then for this loss function we take the derivative,
the derivative is this. So, we can you know this is the actual equation that we use, very
simple equation. And as one of you ask if you change the loss function this derivative
will be different, but this is a very commonly used loss function.
You can use other loss functions definitely, but if the loss function is differentiable
then only you can use this approach ok. You can choose any other differentiable loss function.
This is the most popular loss function that we use. And for this finally, we come up with
this nice article. We say repeat until convergence and in parallel if there are n different parameters
there will be sorry n different features there will be n plus 1 parameters for each parameter
in parallel you can do this. This is a single iteration you update this n plus 1 parameters
next iteration, next iteration until you converge. And if you look at the picture you will get
the idea or this picture you will get the idea if step size is small if you start here
after you know it will always go towards convergence and until you overshoot.
So, after some number of iteration we will converge and what is convergence? At convergence
you will have the derivative to be 0 or close to 0. You can put a small value and when the
derivative reaches that value you can stop, but if the derivative is again going higher
that means you have missed the convergence point ok. So, the cost function is always
a convex function it has a single global minimum. So, gradient descent will always converge
if the step size is small enough. Now, before we take a break just one more thing.
So, in the previous algorithm when we found when we to consider the loss function it is
in terms of all m training data. Now, if you have a lot of training data. So, if you take
the average over all the training data that gives you a good estimate of the actual derivative,
but if you have a lot of training data then you know this becomes too slow right. So,
what you can do is that instead of taking all the training data you can take a small
amount of training data, m is large you can take a smaller number of training data as
the basis of the loss function right. And suppose you have 200 data first you take
10 data with respect to you find the loss then the next 10 then the next 10. So, if
you take a small batch of training data as the basis of finding the gradient of course,
the estimate at each step may not be as accurate, but then the algorithm becomes faster this
is called batch gradient descent. And even if you use batch gradient descent it can be
shown that your algorithm will still converge it may take more steps, but each step is much
faster ok. So, with this we will take a 5 minute break
before we begin. Good morning.